außerdem frühzeitig gewarnt haben dass
die amerikaner vom zusammenbruch
ausgehen dann muss man mal die frage
stellen was macht eigentlich hamas oder
was hat er eigentlich gemacht jetzt
sehen die anliegende länder fahren und
hoffen dass die leute die afghanen
aufnehmen ist ja wohl keine außenpolitik
wie überhaupt
afghanistan die grundsatzfrage nach
deutsche außenpolitik stellt
ich weiß das ist umstritten aber so ein
bundessicherheitsrat wäre zumindest
mal eine überlegung dass
langfristige diskussion über
außenpolitik wieder ins zentrum der
diskussion gestellt werden denn die gibt
es ja heute leider nicht sondern
wir suchen versuchen immer auf seine der
gutmenschen zu stehen und das ergebnis
haben wir nur in afghanistan gesehen und
ich fürchte in mali wird es bald nicht
anders aussehen
dass ortskräfte
offensichtlich kein begriff ist der
eindeutig definiert ist zeigt sich dass
die bundesregierung jetzt alle möglichen
leute unter ortskräfte einordnet und
märkten aus ist so nett uns 41.000 zu
jährlich leute in einem resettlement
programm zu empfehlen da kann ich nur
mit dem bundeskanzler von österreich
sagen
wir nehmen gar kein die auf die
jedenfalls ist ganz dagegen dass der
begriff ortskräfte in einer weise
ausgeweitet wird beispielsweise auf
leute die für entwicklungsprojekte
gearbeitet haben wer für die bundeswehr
gearbeitet hat gegenüber dem haben der
eine verpflichtung bei allen anderen
gilt das normale asylrecht und solange
diejenigen nicht verfolgt sind
kann er hier kein asyl bekommen
der irrsinn ist ja man glaubt dass karl
ich dass da jetzt jemand den wir aus
afghanistan hergekommen ist der schwere
straftaten begangen hat und er kann aber
jetzt nicht mehr abgeschoben werden weil
afghanistan zu gefährlich ist wenn man
sich das nur auf der zunge zergehen
lässt es war man sich ist dieses land
noch völlig ganz normal insofern ich
hoffe dass es am 26
das wird
ja auch zu der frage ob dieses land noch
normal ist gehört die diskussion um die
abfrage des impfstatus wir lehnen eine
abfrage des impfstatus klar ab und es
ist auch ein weiterer schritt zu
indirekten impfpflicht und die
behauptungen von jens spahn dass die
erfassung des impfstatus von
angestellten den kitas und schulen den
schutz der risikogruppen diene blendet
aus dass geimpfte das virus ebenso
übertragen können wie
nicht geimpfte und das kann man derzeit
sehr eindrucksvoll an den zahlen in
israel sehen
und wir haben die befürchtung und das
verdichtet sich jetzt immer mehr dass
dadurch gesunde ungeimpfte diskriminiert
werden diesen land und was wir nicht
zulassen dürfen ist dass es eine
zwei-klassen-gesellschaft gibt hingehe
impft und ungeimpft ich sehe das auch
nicht in unserem grundgesetz im
grundgesetz wird auch nicht
unterschieden zwischen ungeimpft und
geimpft sondern dort steht dass alle
menschen alle bürger vor dem grundgesetz
vor dem recht gleich sind und davon mal
ganz abgesehen sind die daten zur
gesundheit von
arbeitnehmern persönlich und müssen auch
persönlich bleiben das fällt unter den
datenschutz und es darf nicht zu einem
allgemeingut werden dass der status
abgefragt wird und statt dessen fordern
wir eine rückkehr zur normalität
wir wollen die aufhebung aller corona
maßnahmen und man sollte diesen zirkus
um die spaltung der gesellschaft und die
diskriminierung von nicht geimpften
sofort beenden und aufheben denn das tut
uns allen das tut unserem land nicht gut
ja einmal dazu machen sie sich dann
sorgen frau was longo bild bei kindern
angeht wenn man da jetzt einfach sagt
das wäre dann egal weil diese verkraften
das schon irgendwie wenn man die nicht
weiter schützen würde und helgoland sie
sprechen von den orts kräften bei der
bundeswehr mir leuchtet nicht ein warum
ortskräfte die zum beispiel unsere
botschaft unterstützt haben oder die
mitarbeiter des ministeriums für
wirtschaftliche zusammenarbeit ist also
in der entwicklungshilfe auch für das
deutsche ministerium gearbeitet haben
warum die weniger zählen sollten als die
wieder bundeswehr geholfen haben
[Musik]
also erstmal müssen wir bei den zahlen
bleiben wie viele fälle es von schwer
erkrankten kindern gibt das bewegt sich
im promillebereich
teilweise schon mit vorbelastung mit
vorerkrankungen und
dementsprechend muss man das den
risikogruppen selbst also der autonomie
der eltern überlassen ob sie ihre kinder
nun impfen lassen oder nicht das ist
nicht angelegenheit des staates der
staat darf menschen nicht dazu zwingen
egal ob es jetzt erwachsene oder kinder
sind das feld in die autonomie der
familien und ich kann einfach nur sagen
hände weg von unseren kindern
das darf man so nicht machen und ich
halte das auch für rechtswidrig
also
ortskräfte ist ein
offensichtlich sehr vager begriff wenn
jemand an irgendeinem
entwicklungsprojekt gearbeitet hat sehe
ich noch gar nicht dass er in
irgendeiner weise verfolgt ist man sieht
ja sogar bilder das afghanische frauen
in kabul demonstrierten
von daher kann es nicht sein bei der
bundeswehr ist das klar und deutlich
bei der botschaft
will ich mich jetzt nicht festlegen
musste man sehen wie viel das sind und
was sie wirklich gemacht haben bei der
bundeswehr ist eindeutig aber
jetzt sozusagen alle anderen die
irgendwann mal einen deutschen
zugewunken haben zu ort kräften zu
machen und damit im grunde genommen so
eine art resettlement programm
umzusetzen das halten wir für völlig
verfehlt und falsch auch im hinblick auf
das was ich ihnen vorgetragen habe dass
der anteil von straftätern
verhältnismäßig hoch ist
im verhältnis zur zahl der betroffenen
afghanen von daher kann es nicht sein
dass das wort ortskräfte jetzt in einer
weise verwendet wird das keine klare
abgrenzung mehr möglich ist
weil wir jetzt drei wochen bisschen
weniger vor der bundestagswahl
was ist denn eigentlich ihr wahlziel als
spitzenkandidaten wir haben ja bei der
union bewegung der schein
wählerreservoir theoretisch frei zu sein
bisher hat sich bei den umfang der apf
die noch nicht so ein gezahlt was ist
denn ihr wahlziel angesichts von der
union so zwischen 20 und 50 prozent wie
im moment sehen also ich bin mit
wahlzielen grundsätzlich vorsichtig die
gebe ich überhaupt nicht aus wir liegen
bei soliden 10 bis 11% es sind mal mehr
und mal weniger
damit sollten wir sehr zufrieden sein
angesichts der lage in der wir uns
befinden
wir sind in einer sondersituation
corona überlagerte alles thematisch das
hatten wir im jahr 2017 ich auch haben
wir partei tektonisch eine verschiebung
wir haben beispielsweise jetzt 2021
parteien auf dem tableau die die 2017
ich angetreten sind die uns
möglicherweise auch wählerstimmen kosten
und dementsprechend sollten wir sehr
sehr zufrieden sein mit den soliden
umfragewerten obwohl ich da auch sagen
muss auch mit umfragen müssen wir sehr
vorsichtig sein
denn wir können die auswirkungen des
briefwahl anteils und das könnte auch
die meinungsforschungsinstitute noch
nicht richtig einschätzen
wie sich das dann einerseits den
prognosen niederschlägt und danach an
dem tatsächlichen wahlergebnis da gibt
es erhebliche abweichungen wie wir
gesehen haben also das sind alles solche
sonder aspekte und auch weiterhin sie
haben es gerade angesprochen es ist
extrem interessant was ich gerade tut
also wir haben ein finanzminister in der
regierung den olaf scholz der eigentlich
als nicht regierungsmitglied
wahrgenommen wird also dieser wendepunkt
diese wechselstimmung in der bevölkerung
schlägt sich eigentlich nicht nieder in
einer nicht regierungspartei wie es
normalerweise psychologisch der fall
wäre sondern
schlägt sich nieder in den ergebnissen
einer regierungspartei und das zeigt uns
eben auch olaf scholz wurde nicht oder
wird nicht als teil der regierung
angesehen und die spd eben auch nicht
das zeigt uns eben auch das dass der
großteil der wähler
eine wechselstimmung möchte aber doch
das wagnis über eine regierungspartei
hinaus möglicherweise nicht so
progressiv wagt wie man einst vermutet
hat es ist ein phänomen
eine eine einlassung solche bemerkung
und die cdu ist offensichtlich so
entkernt worden von frau merkel dass die
wähler gar nicht mehr wissen wird das
ist ohne frau merkel überhaupt eine
partei gibt und daher lasse diese
politik die ganze zeit mitgemacht hat
ist es fast logisch
dass die leute
von der cdu immer weiter zurückweichen
weil sie sie nicht mehr erkennbar finden
das ist das was wir viele jahre vorher
gesagt haben dass es das was weshalb wir
die afg gegründet haben jetzt erreicht
die union und wenn sie die wahlen
verliert hast du das weniger asche das
vollkommen frau merkt zu verdanken ich
glaube im übrigen auch dass das kein
kurzfristiger trend ist sondern das ist
ein langfristiger trend der sich nicht
mehr umkehren lässt die cdu ist keine
marke mehr für konservative politiker
merkel hat 16 jahre lang politik gegen
das eigene regierungsprogramm von 2005
gemacht völlig diametral gegen das
regierungsprogramm und eine partei die
das durchgehen lässt verliert mitglieder
wie die cdu die haben 100.000 über über
200.000 mitglieder verloren in der
kanzlerschaft angela merkel und sind
enorm in landesverbänden bei den
landtagswahlen abgestürzt von vormals
weit über 40 prozent auf knapp über 20
prozent und das ist natürlich auch etwas
was sich langfristig jetzt niederschlägt
und für die cdu ist eigentlich der point
of no return überschritten
dahinter können sie gar nicht mehr
zurückfallen und wir haben das phänomen
in europäischen ländern das ist
teilweise aufgrund dieser haltung der
entkernung von werten die vier
ehemaligen volksparteien pulverisiert
und das sehe ich ganz klar auch bei der
cdu im langfristigen trend sie hat sich
überflüssig gemacht
erschließt sich mir nicht warum sie
nicht selbstbewusster sagen sie wollen
das ergebnis vom letzten mal dann auch
steigern weil wenn die cdu in so einem
fall ist dann müssen doch ein paar davon
auf die idee kommen jetzt sie zu wählen
oder haben sie nicht bewiesen das was
sie vorhatten in den letzten vier jahren
dass sie die wahre alternative sind mit
ihrer arbeit sie wollten das unter
beweis stellen wieso sind sie dann nicht
selbstbewusster und wollen ein besseres
ergebnis das muss doch die logische
konsequenz sein also ich glaube dass wir
den 26 09 einfach mal abwarten sollten
und wir machen alle die gesamte partei
die ehrenamtlichen funktionäre wir
machen sehr engagierten wahlkampf und
das merkt man auch an der basis und das
macht auch sehr viel freude es macht
sehr viel spaß aber ich bin sehr sehr
vorsichtig was die prognosen und
umfragen anbelangt und dementsprechend
würde ich einfach mal ganz demütig und
konservativ den 26 09 abwarten wollen
und dann können wir weiterreden wir
haben jetzt fraktionssitzung
ja aber das
wären natürlich besser als 12
das hat frau auch nicht anders
ausgedrückt dass ich nicht wenigstens
realistisch und dann landen wir bei 19
wenn wir bei 20 landen und landen bei 19
da würde jeder sagen ja hinter ihrem
eigenen wahlziel zurück geblieben warum
sind denn nur 19 ja so ist das mit wahl
ziehen
sie sehen schon wahlziele taugen nichts
ok danke